A tiny woman against a hulking alien nightmare?
A CGI bear that looks absolutely unbearable?
Some Pred-heads are really gunning for Prey.
By far the biggest complaint among fans is
the controversial redesign of the Predator,
which portrays the creature in a decidedly
more monstrous form than we're used to.
Dubbed "the Feral Predator," it's an ancestor
to the beast seen fighting Arnold Schwarzenegger's
Dutch in the original film, 300 years after
the events of "Prey."
Director Dan Trachtenberg told Digital Spy,
"I wanted to make this version of the Predator
so much more feral and ferocious and animalistic,
from its movements to its silhouette and its
design."
While Trachtenberg's explanation makes sense,
some "Predator" fans have responded negatively
to the new look, which is revealed during
an action scene midway through the film.
You don't need to look further than the comments
section on the fan website AVP Galaxy to see
the disdain many have for the design.
For instance, one user said,
"Feral's weapons were interesting and it was
fun watching him on screen.
My one gripe is that I wasn't crazy about
the face redesign.
It was just okay for me."
Similar sentiments appear in various comment
circles across the web, though the new look
does have several fans.
One user is quoted as saying,
"'Prey' is a solid #predator movie.
Predator redesign seemed unnecessary, but
didn't bother me.
Way better than expected."
The predator seen in "Prey" lives up to the
species' storied reputation.
The big guy hunts and kills a rattlesnake,
a wolf, a bear, a group of Comanches, and
a whole squad of French trappers in brutal
fashion.
These scenes offer some of the best action
of the entire "Predator" franchise, as the
alien baddie utilizes an assortment of unique
weapons and abilities to take out his foes.
Perhaps that's why some fans were left feeling
short changed at the monster's demise.
Following his trail of carnage, the hunter
chases Naru, who stole his mask in a previous
scene, into the forest and eventually becomes
stuck in some mud.
He disappears below the surface but manages
to pull himself out of the trap long enough
to aim his arrow launcher at Naru's head,
unaware that the clever warrior has placed
his mask on a nearby tree.
"This is as far as you go.
No more.
This is it."
Our antagonist can only tilt his head in confusion
before an arrow streaks through his skull,
killing him instantly.
A Twitter user noted,
"The Predator dies in what I think is the
dumbest way for a Predator to die . . . It
would be a badass kill if he didn't stand
there looking all 'oh s--' for a few good seconds."
Another complaint about "Prey" among fans
is the Predator's inability to kill a young
woman with minimal combat experience.
One user made a composite image of the entire
cast of the original "Predator" film standing
next to Naru, indicating that it took an entire
squad of trained soldiers to take down the
original monster, but only a single, inexperienced
warrior to succeed in the latest film.
One could argue the point of Naru's character
arc is to show the merits of brains over brawn
in outwitting an interstellar killing machine.
That isn't convincing enough for some, including
one Twitter user, who states,
"In this movie the predator 1 punch kills
a 1k pound grizzly but can't strangle the
110-pound protag even when it has its hand
around her neck."
One could also point out that a theme of the
entire original "Predator" film is "brains over brawn."
Dutch is the last one standing because he
realizes that the combat experience and physical
might of his team are no match for the kind
of clever strategy that both he and Naru rely
on in their climactic battles.
"Prey" is not a perfect film.
There's plenty to love, but this "Predator"
prequel has some glaring issues - notably,
the wonky CGI.
Many of the animals in the movie look a little
off - especially during the bear fight.
Even fans who like the film point out that
some of the visual effects in this sequence
are simply not up to modern blockbuster standards.
One critic said,
"A couple of intro shots of the bear were
not very good.
Later on when the bear and Predator were fighting
was much much better, but you can tell they
were like, 'This part doesn't matter all that
much, but this next part will be in the trailer.'
It was a little rough."
Another tweeted,
"Prey was basically 'what if the power rangers
movie had very bad CGI?'"
Though that same user went on to praise the
action scenes overall, they clearly had no
love for the distracting special effects.
Naru is largely seen as a misfit by her fellow
tribesmen who don't support her rebellious ways.
In fact, except for her brother Taabe, no
one steps up to support Naru or her quest
to become a great hunter.
"Who invited you?
We won't be gone long enough to need a cook."
But the understatement of this aspect is one
of the reasons some critics praised "Prey,"
with one noting,
"The subtle approach to the arc of Naru is
appreciated as [the filmmakers] rarely resort
to forced antagonism via the tribespeople
to make their point."
Some fans don't agree, including the hosts
of The Angry Movie Review, who cite the scene
in which one of the men in Naru's tribe orders
her to go back to the village.
The critic argues that while the explicit
bullying makes for easy conflict, it also
feels a little dumbed down.
The others on the show agreed, feeling that
while the overall purpose of the scene was
fine, the silly dialogue undercuts the tension,
saying,
"Instead of hokey dialogue, it could have
all been done in looks or different ways.
Just adult it up a little bit."
"Prey" ends much like the original "Predator,"
with Naru defeating the alien hunter by utilizing
her wits and escaping with her life.
Some have complained that Naru should have
been roughed up a bit more during her battle
with the Predator, noting that even Arnold
Schwarzenegger was left bloodied and broken
at the end of the original film.
One user makes the point that even after she
massacres the alien, Naru doesn't have a mark on her.
They go on to note that the team from "Predator"
had difficulty bringing down the original
alien even with their high-tech weaponry.
A Reddit user stated that they enjoyed "Prey,"
but added that they missed how clever the
predator used to be.
They went on to lament how the Predators no
longer seem like much of a threatening presence
after a few movies that have seen them be
beaten with relative ease.
An aspect of "Prey" drawing criticism from
fans is the lack of memorable supporting characters.
It's almost a tradition for "Predator" films
to feature great ensembles surrounding the
central protagonist in their battle with the
alien hunter.
John McTiernan's original 1987 film included
the likes of Carl Weathers, Bill Duke, Sonny
Landham, and Jesse Ventura, among others.
While later sequels arguably dipped in quality
from the original, Hit or Miss TV host Andrew
Tate opined that even the lesser films had
solid supporting casts.
He argues,
"Prey doesn't have supporting characters other
than the brother - the lead character's brother.
He's in it - I thought he was really good
- but he wasn't in it enough.
There wasn't enough development."
Tate felt none of the deaths in "Prey" really
mattered, explaining,
"There's too many other characters that get
wiped out and I'm just like, 'Oh well, it's
just another generic NPC from Skyrim.
I don't care about them.'"
One four out of ten rating on IMDb had a fairly
scathing review, stating,
"The Comanche people portrayed in the film
have only one thing to live for - survival
. . . It also makes it very hard for them
to be personable and likable.
Every character in the film other than the
main girl might as well have been the exact same person."
One of Arnold Schwarzenegger's most iconic
one-liners comes from the original "Predator."
"If it bleeds, we can kill it."
The same line is repeated in "Prey" by Naru's
brother Taabe, while they're both tied to
a tree during the battle sequence with the
French fur trappers.
For some, the moment was a goosebump-inducing
callback to "Predator," but others felt the
bit of dialogue felt shoehorned into the film.
One tweet described the line as being shoehorned
into Prey for no reason.
In the comment section below the tweet, the
user posited,
"It would have been better if they gave one
of Billy's lines to them.
'There's something hunting us, and it ain't
no man . . . we're all gonna die.'
And then they all indeed die."
About midway through "Prey," Naru comes to
a startling conclusion while tied up to a
tree with her brother: the Predator won't
kill her because it doesn't see her as a threat.
This ties into the overall theme of "Prey."
Naru is trying to prove her worth to those
around her, while many in her tribe see her
as little more than someone who needs to learn
her place.
However, some fans were angered by this twist.
In their negative review of the film, Bad
Movie Reviews claimed,
"The movie constantly panders to gender politics
as apparently, in this movie, the Predator
isn't attacking the female lead because it
doesn't see her as a threat . . . Since when
does the Predator care about the gender of
its victims?"
In the comment section for the same video,
a user noted that the Predator slaughtered
the fatally injured fur trapper Raphael despite
knowing he didn't have a weapon and was physically hampered.
He explains,
"He certainly wasn't a threat, but that didn't
stop the predator from killing him."
Others in the comments agree with another
user arguing,
"Don't let anyone fool you, Predators have
attacked women with weapons in other movies.
Only exception was [Predator 2], where the
woman was pregnant and he didn't."
In one particular way, "Prey" seems to be
messing with "Predator" franchise lore, which
is a bad idea when dealing with hardcore fandom.
The character of Raphael Adolini plays a huge
part in the franchise, at least in terms of
comic books and spinoffs.
Adolini was the name inscribed on the gun
given to Danny Glover by one of the departing
Predators at the end of "Predator 2," seemingly
as a sign of respect.
For years, fans wondered who this mysterious
man was and why a Predator would carry around
his weapon, clearly seeing it as some sort
of prized trophy to be handed off when bested in combat.
As it turns out, the answers lie in a 1996
Dark Horse comic book titled "Predator: 1718,"
a storyline "Prey" completely ignores.
Instead, the film features a man named Raphael,
who is killed by the Predator after handing
his flintlock pistol to Naru.
While it's neat to see the "Predator 2" Easter
Egg in "Prey," the complete disregard for
previous comic book canon has disappointed
some, much like Disney's retconning of pre-existing
"Star Wars" Expanded Universe stories.
One of the coolest scenes in "Prey" features
Naru taking out a group of French trappers
using her throwing axe and some well-timed
flips.
Shot to look like one long take, the sequence
is violent, gory, and completely badass as
Naru slices and dices enemies left and right
without remorse.
Still, there were quite a few fans who decried
the moment as unbelievable.
A Reddit user noted that Naru was mostly seen
as "useless" by her tribe for much of the
film, continuing,
"Then when the movie calls for it she can
suddenly slaughter a camp of 10 or so men
in 45 seconds . . . It would have been a better
step imo for her to have been a capable hunter
and warrior . . . rather than making her instantly
go into beast mode for the last 15-20 minutes."
Others have joked that Naru's abilities are
more akin to Keanu Reeves' killer assassin
in "John Wick" than a real-life Indigenous
warrior.
One tweet jokes,
"Naru in 'Prey' is very obviously the founder
of the assassins guild in John Wick.
The obvious fact that John Wick, Predator,
& Alien is a shared universe is basically
the greatest gift 2022 could have given me."